Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 6 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs in references.
We'll break it all down.
Also, kind of seems like they've set up
a potential nemesis for Morty.
Like the next overarching villain in the show.
After Rick Prime.
Everybody beware. Cheery. The Immortal Gyro.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
And careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs in WTF moments,
starting with the episode title.
Rick Vending your more.
Which is a reference to the movie
Defending your Life with Albert Brooks is all about him
having to stand up for his life, trying
to prove that he's worthy of getting into heaven.
during the episode, Rick and Morty are put on trial
literally
by the observers and have to defend their lives
or else they'll be killed.
the episode was mostly a parody of a clip show,
like a soft sequel to Morty's Mind Blowers,
or the same type of trope.
Making fun of the whole trope
in general of clip shows themselves
like they call it out a couple of times
during the episode,
which is something that Rick casually does
all the time, like he'll point out
or make fun of tropes all over the place.
Generally, the episode is meant to be like
a lighter fare after last week's
super canonical, super serious Episode
five ending to the saga of Rick
versus Rick Prime and him getting some kind of closure,
if you can call it that.
sort of answers the next big question who is the next
main villain of the Rick and Morty series?
Is it going to be cheery? The Immortal Churro.
part of me thinks that this was just meant to be like a
one off bit like haha, everybody be afraid of this
tiny little churro that can now
be the super powerful enemy because he cannot die.
He's literally called immortal.
theoretically,
that would make him a threat bigger than Rick Prime.
But remember, he only hates Morty and wants to
strand him unable to die on a desert planet Legacies.
I'm going to do the same thing to
you will probably happen in the future,
though, is it they'll introduce some other main villain
at some point, maybe like the season finale.
But if we don't hear about Shuri
The Churro before season seven episode ten,
I expect them to maybe just reference it in some loose
joke in a future season, and that's about it.
during the opening scene, Morty finds
Rick in the garage drunk as hell,
just like Evel Morty
did during his back story last week.
For those of you asking where his drool has been,
he's got a ton of it In this episode.
when Rick says he doesn't feel like
going on an adventure right now, but definitely next
week, that's sort of a meta joke about the actual show
itself, like him kind of breaking the fourth wall.
Like we'll do a traditional adventure
in next week's episode.
Another reference to Rick
knowing that he's a fictional character in the show.
Morty also does that in this episode too,
So they both kind of break the fourth wall
a couple of times in the episode,
Morty tries to cash in his free
adventure punch card from back in season three.
We've seen them a couple of times since then. it
every time Rick makes him go on
an adventure that he doesn't want to go
on, he gets to punch the card.
it's a bit that actually started during season
two in MI6 in Destroy, when Morty won a bet,
which they referenced
playing an actual clip of this episode,
later paying off the whole bit
about this being an actual clip show,
like even though Morty's mind blowers
was kind of like a clip show.
They were all brand new animated clips,
except that we hadn't seen on the show previously.
Rick thinks Morty has been forging the cards.
They're worthless
which Morty cops to later in the episode only
some of them are meant to be valid and count
towards Morty's free Adventures.
Rick also references the Gremlins movie.
there's actually a non-canonical Rick and Morty
Claymation Gremlins episode from the early seasons.
Do Morty whips out a record of a bunch of different
adventures that they've been on three different pages.
We don't see every single one,
but we do see most of them zombie
logs, Death Race just sounds like a parody of the Death
Race movie Memory Planet.
In a Memory of a Memory Planet.
Sounds like a riff on Morty's mind blowers
because this episode is kind of
like a sequel to Morty's Mind Blowers in.
They show a bunch of vignettes
of their previous adventures.
Labradoodle, Brain. Hi.
Sounds like something to do with snowball or sniffles,
however you want to think of them
interplanetary
cricket World Cup is exactly what it sounds like.
also the fact that there's an interplanetary
cricket league.
Like cricket is somehow the most popular sport
in the galaxy and Rick is a fan of it.
Isle of the Morty source.
Sounds like Rick or Morty messed up
and accidentally created a bunch
of Morty dinosaurs that now live on an island
somewhere.
Beanie Baby Zombie Apocalypse Times
two Sounds like Rick or Morty
accidentally brought Beanie Babies
back to life as zombies.
Then they had to kill them, But then one of them
did it again and they accidentally had to repeat it.
dark brunch just sounds like some sinister
human spaghetti level type of brunch.
Regional Plumbing Convention
makes it sound like it was some regular convention
that they wound up doing something super messed up at.
takes one to no one.
Sounds like it could be absolutely anything.
Let me know in the comments what you think
that one was Getting good at yo yo trick.
Sounds like something that Rick wanted to do
and engineered some over-the-top
crazy science plot to make himself, like, the greatest
yo yo Ah, in the universe.
chicken sandwich waffle.
Sounds like something that Rick wanted, like some kind
of comfort food, but it's an actual dish in real life.
It actually tastes delicious if you haven't had it.
soda can grenade business sounds like a Morty idea
that Rick kind of hijack like Rick turned
the soda cans into something more dangerous
than actual grenades Rick reveals
that Morty lied about a bunch of stories
that he read for an EMS reader Thorn charity at school
like he lied and wrote down a bunch of fake stories
that he never actually read.
Then Rick reveals he has a cosmic observer
who records everything he and the family do.
24 seven like a cosmic CCTV.
is basically a parody of The Guardian of Forever
from Star Trek in the Watchers from Marvel.
Like we've got the What If series that I'll be doing
episode videos for in a couple of weeks.
The Watcher will be coming back during that.
we also saw a live action versions of the Watchers
during Guardians of the Galaxy two.
Rick makes a joke
about police
turning their body cams off and beating people up.
then finally they payoff.
One of the intro scenes in this week's episode
with Benjamin Franklin Pet Cemetery bit Inside No.
Two in the trailer for episode seven next week, the
scene of summer lifting Rick in the intro also appears.
So we're getting like two episodes
back to back with scenes from the intro.
Like they save all the intro scene payoffs
for like the second half of the season.
the first adventure clip is for an adventure
called Truth or Dare, which is basically a parody
of Legend of Zelda games.
You could call it a reference to either
like Breath of the Wild or Tears of the Kingdom,
but it looks pretty similar to both.
Rick referencing the tutorial from both of those games.
they set up a running gag in the episode about dudes
cheating
with other dudes wives like versus
the Golems from the Zelda plan.
And then later it's the judge in the lawyer's
wife Morty,
even comments on the fact that it's a big running gag
at the end of the episode.
Like, wow, this happens a lot.
everybody hide your wife.
the late night Western adventure.
Was Rick getting drunk, making Morty
go to Carl's Junior
to get him a Western bacon burger
because Rick had been banned from the restaurant.
No idea what he did at that restaurant.
This is also a bit of a joke about the Carl's Jr
commercials that Rick and Morty has done in the past.
They've actually been a bunch of them.
wake up.
Won a Carl's Jr Hardee's commercial right now.
I'd like you to meet some characters.
Thick burger, El Diablo.
I don't want to be in a car show four in the morning.
I got a big test tomorrow.
But you, me,
all natural dirt comes here to help you relax.
Murray Christian Bacon Cheeseburger
Patio six Burger.
You we get a look at one of the other pages
of Murray's adventures.
One of them is the five nights at Freddy's simulation.
But in real life, Like Rick made real Ghost,
which we actually saw him do in a previous episode,
then made those inhabit the bodies of the animatronics
based on five nights at Freddy's.
they probably did this joke knowing
that the five nights at Freddy's movie was coming out
pretty close to this during the year it's literally
like the highest grossing horror movie all year long.
is even earning more money
than a lot of the Marvel movies.
Maximum Overdrive with Close is based on the maximum
Overdrive movie,
which was directed by Stephen King
based on one of his short stories.
It was technically his first and last
directing gig back in the day.
the hoity in the context of that story is that a car
is brought to life like inanimate
objects start coming to life after a comet passes
nearby Earth.
so in this world it's like the same idea
only is just with clothes, whispering.
Dixie is a Blade movie parody with Rick and Morty
dressed up as blades, which might actually
be the payoff to their memory
from the season five episode one of the intro
where they saw an alternate universe
version themselves who became blades
the Whistling Dixie reference is to him waffling,
basically droning on and on and on with Whistler
just going on about the special anti vampire gun
that he made for so long that Rick and Morty
get bored in bail on the adventure,
leaving him to be killed by the other vampires.
Notice his gun is called the Holy Soaker,
which is a reference to Super soaker guns.
Marvel is actually in the middle of trying
to make a rated R blade movie with Mahershala Ali.
Probably going to be a couple of years
before we see that, though.
They have a whole bit about 911.
And Rick trying to get Morty in trouble on Twitter
for posting about it
Leg day is a parody of Pickle Rick
with Rick turning himself into a lake.
And he also reveals that he's done
this on multiple occasions.
Like that was the second time that I did like Rick
The Morty actually kind of breaks the fourth wall,
which is super rare.
Like Morty usually doesn't break the fourth wall
when he calls Rick's leg.
Rick T-shirt, bootleg merch for the show, revealing
that Morty also knows this is a fictional character
in a TV show in Rick and Morty.
Merchandise for the show needs to be licensed.
Then the observer starts to play
a bunch of his own bits that he'd recorded of them
taking over the episode.
Basically the first one is a parody of Morty
turning into a car.
Previously on the show.
This time he turns into a boat
and it turns into like a castaway movie parody.
Like the Tom Hanks movie.
they get Stranded on the Island R.I.P.
Big Doug until Rick comes to bring him
for another adventure in the hamster that he says he's
lost control of escapes onto the island,
implying that the hamster then killed the other kid
when the Observer mentions the series of clips
he's got have a thematic connection.
That's also a reference to something
that Dan Harmon used to talk about
during the early seasons of the show.
I think season one or season two
about connecting A and B storyline in an episode
at the end of the episodes basically thinking of that
is like a trope in not wanting to do it.
they said that the running gag about the observers,
all of them all over
reality, literally recording every possible thing ever.
24 seven like this one watches them bad mouthing.
Then later in the episode
it gets super meta with observers observing each other
in some of them misusing their powers
of watching things to literally pirate movies.
it comes back to harass them from the sidewalk,
making fun of Rick, trying to go all keto diet
the ape cyborg memory was probably one of my favorite
just because it went so deeply.
There were so many layers to this first off
it seems like a dragonball reference with it
going super saying like they're great ape forms
and then fighting on an asteroid.
then, it seems like this
salty Rick's bar was actually on the citadel of Rick's
when it still existed, and Rick would go there,
and each of the different Rick's there would visit
the bar, would compete in challenges
trying to make their mortes do different crazy things.
so it wasn't just see 137
trying to complete these challenges.
It was like all these different rigs
that would come here trying to get their mornings
to do crazy stuff.
some of the other challenges were getting Morty
married to Mr.
Poopy Butthole,
which we saw during Morty's mind blowers revealing
that that was the result of a
bet that Rick was trying to win here.
believing that he's a ghost,
a murder suicide pact with the U.S.
president.
Common law marrying a hippo means that he had to live
with a hippo for over ten years.
It's like Rick had to convince Morty
to live with the hippo for over ten years.
Chugging salad dressing.
Does it really seem all that special?
Becoming Santa Claus, though, might actually mean
literally becoming Santa Claus, not just dressing up
like one during Christmas and then drinking
toilet water is pretty self-explanatory.
Maybe they meant dirty toilet water.
But really, is there any other kind of toilet water?
Like it's all dirty?
then the family shows up
and they start playing clips for each of them.
Beth's toilet wine also revealing
this summer, was drinking from that same bottle
like I know what that sounds like.
Like she knew the sound because she herself
had been stealing wine from that toilet.
Jerry gets stuck by a bunch of Rick's chemicals
when he tries to grab a diamond from the trash
and winds up turning his piss into acid
and causing him to piss on his coworkers downstairs
and show them his junk, flashing them side.
No, this would have also had to have been
when he had an actual job,
which he currently does not have one
and has not had one for a long time.
So this must be an old memory.
Also note that he's
self-aware at this point, like he's made his peace
with being the most ridiculous member of the family.
Like I'm supposed to be stupid summers whole bit
about not being a hot person and being horrified
also seems like a callback to her
trying to make her boobs bigger to get boys
to like her space Beth farts during a mission briefing
led by third person who we know is still alive.
We saw him a couple of episodes ago
correctly outing her as the father because his beak is
supersensitive.
Notice their mission was against a wrongful
might call Dichotomous Daniel
There's also a female squashy here too,
like another member of squad.
She's race
this druid on her left seems like a Star Wars pit
droid reference
to some of these memories are also kind of random too.
Like they get really quick about it.
Morty stealing money from Rick's wallet,
that seems pretty common.
Rick.
Creating a Morty dog like Morty's face
using him to win.
Best in show at a dog competition.
Maybe that was actual Morty that he turned into a dog.
Then they had to jump into a vat of whale semen
with Beth
calling it out as a trope like,
you just did that for shock value.
then Morty gets the Observer killed
when it's hit by a passing car,
setting up them, having to actually defend their lives
from the Observer's race.
as their hanging there in Stacy's, they later revealed
that Rick was just kind of going along
with this, biding his time so that he could gain
control of their technology, allowing them to escape
paying off the bit again about his inspector gadget
body parts like he has so much of his body replaced.
This time he has a third arm, basically, when Rick says
that he and Morty already did this whole trial thing
with the Giants, that's a reference to MI6
and destroy the episode where Morty initially won
the bet in the rights to use the punch cards
which they used to tee off this entire episode.
And they literally played the clip from MI6 and destroy
paying off the bit about this being a clip show parody,
all the other clips that they show were brand new stuff
that we didn't see in previous episodes.
when they make fun of Rick and Morty for repeating
their mistakes, it's also a reference to long running
shows like Rick and Morty, The Simpsons, South Park,
all repeating jokes from earlier episodes like,
you already did this bit in a previous episode,
they have the bit about Morty messing up all the guns
that Rick gives him because Rick has really vague
explanations about what the guns actually do.
This one is only for killing gorillas, the bully gun
that he thinks will turn him into a bully winds up
killing him, then Rick has to bring him back to life
in the gun that just shoots Jeffrey Dahmer's.
Maybe the idea
is that they eat the people that they get shot at.
And that's the joke.
Like they run off before that winds up happening.
But they also reveal that during this adventure,
he was on a date with Jessica.
So go, Morty.
and they revealed that there were several more guns
as part of this bit like it went on and on and on.
they do the cemetery bit with them,
trying to test the limits of how it actually works,
starting with Ben Franklin.
they try to use it to recharge Morty's phone
to fix a broken car.
And you can see a bunch of stuff strewn
about like they try to a bunch of different ways.
Rick wanting to eat.
The Ben Franklin is also a callback
to the human spaghetti episode.
they show Morty creating his new nemesis,
Cherry the Churro, who is immortal.
Like it's already kind of explained the bit basically,
they stick them on a plane.
That's kind of a reference to Star Trek
to Wrath of Khan, like stranding him on a planet.
The other thing, too, is that when Morty asks Rick
to bring the Churro to life,
he shot it with his gun immediately.
No time wasted, meaning that Rick has a gun
that can make things immortal.
Which makes it way, way more powerful than we thought
before
they had the whole Wes Anderson parody montage
about a bunch of his movies.
This hotel is based on the French Dispatch.
All the shots of them are scenes
framed in a Wes Anderson style of filmmaking
this is a joke about the quirky types of scenes in West
Anderson movies that they're all
sitting in hot tubs and all the scenes,
but none of the hot tubs have any water in them.
these two outfits are from the Life
Aquatic movie, like this one.
And the Snorkel the other bit with the churros, too,
is that when they stranded him on the plane in January,
the churro expected to find other living churros
like, it's my family,
but but then realizes they're just regular churros
meaning that Rick
created a bunch of other living churros
and they would also be immortal.
is like a small race of immortal churros out there
that all hate Morty,
there's a big joke about Rick Mercy
killing the Rick and Morty who are in the new Space
Jam movie confirming that those versions
were not the main versions of the characters.
if you didn't see that movie, do not worry,
It was terrible.
Save yourself the time, Then Rick tricks them
into giving him enough time
to finish hacking their tech
and causing them to devolve into fighting each other.
Basically killing each other off,
allowing them to escape,
showing them a bunch of scenes of them
misusing their powers
when they show the ones selling bootleg
movies, there's Avatar three through six, basically,
like all the Avatar movies that James Cameron
announced, there's a copy of the Batgirl movie,
which was famously canceled
by Warner Brothers, the company
that now owns Adult Swim and the Rick and Morty Show.
So like making fun of the company that owns them.
Also the same company that released the Space
Jam movie.
he's also got the Social Network, too, a sequel
to the first movie in Oppenheimer's sequel in This one
seems like a sequel to the story Train movie
because it's got the same character on the cover.
there's a sequel to the Amsterdam movie,
which itself was not a good movie.
And there's a Babylon sequel movie.
the whole bit about the Avatar
friends and family screening without any effects
is that a lot of movies in real life screened early
to get audience reactions in.
They do it for the cast and crew members,
friends and family.
Marvel used to do this all the time,
but they had a big problem with spoilers getting out,
so they stopped doing it us a fake name again.
Again, Not sure.
You know,
I just don't understand why he keeps doing this.
You don't understand.
I feel like it's pretty obvious. Think.
I don't spoil things.
I think they mean one thing that I've actually spoiled
when Rick says that he believes
marriage is a scam
that probably started after his wife, Diane, was killed
because he seemed pretty happy
to be married to her back at that time.
They bargained for Morty's next free adventure insert,
referencing
next week's episode saying that they're on their way
to have another traditional adventure.
Basically, next week basically means episode seven.
they also pay off the bit
from back in the spaghetti episode where they said
that Morty would have to stop morally questioning
Rick for a couple episodes, meaning two episodes in.
It's been two episodes.
So that's why Morty, at the end of the episode here,
says, Maybe I'll morally question you.
Rick also giving him another gun, which he'll probably
use to accidentally killed himself or someone else.
during the Post-Credits scene, they pay off the jury
the churro bit revealing that he's escaped the planet
and is now just stalking Morty,
waiting to capture him and strand him somewhere
there are a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode
if you spotted any that I didn't talk about it in
the video, just write them below in the comments
and let me know if you think that they're going
to bring this cheery the churro bit back on the show,
or they'll just completely introduce
a totally different main villain in a couple episodes.
My assumption right now
is that they'll probably wait to like the finale
and they'll introduce like whoever
the next real big villain is going to be.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Like I said, my what if season two episodes will start
at the end of December when they start airing
Be sure to enable alerts on my channels
so you don't miss that.
Click here for the trailer video for that and
Click here for all my other Rick and Morty Episodes.
Thank you so much for watching
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!